hi Samuel eensy I hope you've had a
wonderful Estep I have been researching
for you guys the root problems and the
challenges that have been stopping you
and holding you back in your property
investment journey so in this video I
wanted to expose all those excuses and
over the next few weeks and months I'm
gonna be kicking the butt of those and
opening the door for you to step into
financial freedom this year as you
probably know if you've been watching
this channel for a while now I'm on an
absolute mission to help 50 people this
year become financially free last year I
helped 36 people become financially free
this year I want to help 50 and I posted
a question on a facebook community group
property investors with Samuel EADS if
you're not on the Facebook community
group there is a link below you can join
for free and I ask the question what's
your biggest challenge or obstacle
problem in property investing this year
and there was way over a hundred
different answers but they all boil down
to 16 answer 16 challenges 16 problems
so I wanted to just read them out right
now because there's a list and if you
are not financially free already chances
are is because of one of these things so
this is the root problem so I'm going to
read this out and expose it and if you
have a dick if there's any other reasons
please do comment below I'd also love to
know which is your strongest challenge
which is your strongest obstacle and
then what I'm gonna do is after I've
exposed these reasons I'm then gonna
work through over the coming weeks and
most and absolutely giving you solutions
to these root problems so that you have
no excuses and you can walk into
financial freedom I hope that sounds
good so the different reasons I'm going
to read these up real quick the first
one is you can't get a mortgage second
is don't know which mortgage to choose
so it HMO single that like confused over
different mortgages have not got a
deposit or in debt
struggling to source the right deal just
getting your first day or getting your
foot in the door you've had a deal for
through or maybe multiple deals and you
just can't cope with the disappointment
right now and you don't want to have to
step into that again knowing that you'll
be able to buy and refinance and pull
your money out raising the finance for
the deal in the first place
finding no money down bills that could
be a challenge for some of you you know
about the lease option agreement some
rector X but you just can't find these
types of deals having a lack of
knowledge getting your wife or husband
onside
really important not living in the UK
unsure of your strategy having too many
deals to choose from and lastly number
16 is having the confidence in yourself
to actually step out and do this stuff
so those are the reasons so I'd love to
know if you could please comment below
which is your strongest challenge and is
there any other challenges that I
haven't said that you'd love me to cover
so that's the problem side of this video
the solution side of this video is this
over the next few weeks and months I'm
going to be doing a video because I
can't answer each one of these problems
in like 20 seconds if I did this whole
in one video it'll be like a 2 or 3 hour
video so I'm going to be doing a video
week where I'm gonna be addressing
specifically these challenges these
problems if you think that sounds like a
good idea let me know and then lastly I
have a problem as well and I really want
your feedback I've been doing this
YouTube video now for every week on a
Monday at 7 p.m.
giving content out and it's been going
really well and I've actually been
amazed at the impact it's had the amount
of people have messaged me privately and
said you know I've quit my job or I'm
just in a deal it's absolutely fantastic
and my challenge is then order for me to
go through all this and do the stuff I
had planned anyway like to show you
around some of my investment properties
that I'm buying and to give you tools to
hit that you hit interviews with some of
the up my mentors expert speakers some
of white for Success students to do all
that I'm really struggling to be able to
do that just once a week if I mean just
this alone would take those 4 months to
get through so my thought process was to
maybe start doing
videos a week so one on a Monday at 7
p.m. and then maybe want on a Wednesday
or Thursday however that is going to be
quite time intensive for me and I'm just
wondering with just now we've had the
baby come along and we've just moved
house just thinking have I got time to
do two videos a week so my question is
if you want it bad enough if you want
two videos please let me know subscribe
like comment let me know if I know that
you're going to watch the videos and
you're going to implement the videos or
well do two videos a week I look forward
to seeing you next week and in the
meantime I just want to say a massive
thank you we've now basically hit 5,000
subscribers tomorrow I believe will be
hitting 5,000 subscribers so I'm really
overwhelmed at that thank you for
believing in me as your YouTube trainer
and coach and all those that have been
to our training programs thank you for
believing in me but more importantly
thank you for believing in you and thank
you for implementing what you've been
learning it's a real real honor to over
you guys so look for just in your
comments don't forget to add yourself
into the Facebook you into group as well
you'll get a lot of value there and have
a wonderful wonderful week
[Music]
you
[Music]